[MUSIC PLAYING]
CANDICE ERICKSON:
Today I'm going
to show you how to set
up a professional PHP
environment in the cloud using
Zend Server with the Google
Cloud Launcher.
After starting the Cloud
Launcher home page,
click Infrastructure,
then click Zend Server.
Next, click Launch
on Compute Engine.
Select an existing project
or create a new one
for your Zend Server instance.
For this example, I'll
pick an existing project,
then click Continue.
After the page loads, you can
configure your new instance.
Give the instance a name
and deployment zone.
You can also configure
additional details
that apply to your project.
When you're finished, click the
Deploy button at the bottom.
Once it is loaded, you'll
see all the details
you need to get started with
your Zend Server instance.
Note the username and
password and click Launch.
That brings up the
Zend Server login page.
Type your username and
password, and click Log In.
That's all there is to it.
To get started with Zend
Server on Cloud Launcher, click
on the link in the comments.
And thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]